[Music]
you
hey youtubers it's Charlie so we finally
got the rest of the Justice League
teasers so there's going to be a whole
bunch of comic-book stuff happening this
weekend be sure to subscribe to get it
all there's an injustice to giveaway
going on so I'll explain at the end of
the video - all you have to do to enter
just be a subscriber leave a comment on
this video so let's freak out about this
the coolest thing I mean we get to see
cyborg activates some of his mother box
enhanced technology I'll explain that in
a second but I think the biggest reveal
here because we all know what cyborg is
we've seen them in the comics a billion
times the biggest reveal is Batman's
flying box when Wonder Woman is walking
in so this is what it looks like and if
you couldn't tell from the other teasers
like whenever cyborg is activating his
technology here they're all standing on
the back of it like when he chucks
Aquaman his spear is like they're
getting ready to roll out leading to
this moment where the back drops out and
getting ready to kick some ass or
something like that so obviously it's
still no Superman not expecting him in
the trailer but it would be crazy if
they revealed them because I think a lot
of people are questioning why you don't
put him in the marketing materials but
it's almost like vision in the last
Avengers age of Ultron trailer he's kind
of like the secret weapon that you know
is going to be in the film but it's such
a special moment when he appears that
they want to save that for as long as
possible they want to give that right
away it's going to come around
eventually - but if you couldn't tell
from the Wonder Woman footage you know
she works in the lube she works in
antiquities because she's been around
for so long the cool thing about this is
that the statue that she's working on is
a statue of Artemis who's kind of like
their patron saint she will actually
show up during the Wonder Woman movie
Artemis herself this is the actress they
cast for her if you're not familiar with
her like I had to look her up because
I'm not really familiar with female
boxers but she's like this real world
retired badass boxer from way back in
the day so imagine like a female
Muhammad Ali is the goddess that all the
Amazons are worshipping to it just seems
very appropriate but all the CG on
cyborgs here looks way better than the
stuff we've seen in the past it's
probably one of the hardest things for
them to get right and takes the longest
to accomplish because this is what he
looks like when he's walking around on
set he doesn't like 100% CG so his body
can morph in that way he can create
anything that he needs to do and he
travels around by boomtube there's like
a bit of a teaser fort
he blasts that debris with his candy
saving these people here you don't see
it right away but in the comics in the
cartoons pretty much every version of
the character travels around using
apocalyptic technology boom - he opens
wormholes to other places so I was
talking a little bit about the mother
boxes in the last teaser trailer video
that I posted some of you were confused
about cyborgs being part mother box he's
a normal person who gets fused with a
mother box and that's what creates the
things that you're looking at here if
you remember the animated movie Justice
League war I wasn't a huge fan of it it
was okay it told the new 52 origin story
of the Justice League but it shows you
how he becomes part mother box when it
fuses with him so it's kind of this
horrific existence for him because he
has these human parts like his human
mind that's trying to make sense of all
this information that he's processing
he's basically was the most powerful
supercomputer on the earth so one he
doesn't sleep and - because he's created
from apocalyptic technology he just has
this really strong tie to the forces of
Darkseid so I think part of his arc in
the film is in trying to retain his
humanity with all this machine stuff
that's going on think about someone
being turned into a terminator and still
trying to maintain that Arnold
Schwarzenegger t2 persona where you can
be good without having to be completely
reprogrammed so I'll be really curious
to see if for a brief part of the film
we see him go rogue because the mother
box part of him takes control in the
human side of him gets suppressed a lot
of you are probably thinking this - is
it a movie that you watch - get ready
for cyborg and Justice League his arc
and sort of like what's going on with
his humanity is the original Robocop
movie just a total awesome eighty flick
about a dude that gets turned into a
weapon that tries to not be the thing
that they turned him into is also very
similar to the wolverine arc in the
Logan movie don't be the thing that they
created you to be don't be a weapon so
in Justice League just imagines that
Darkseid is turning him into a weapon
but you can actually watch that process
during the Batman V Superman sequence
when they're watching the video files
that Lex Luthor ad
[Music]
2200 hours and 2 minutes subjects
declining rapidly all procedural
intervention have failed outcome
pucusana stone suspending all clinical
protocol u.s. code object 6 1982
successfully activated
[Music]
so he'll already be that character when
we meet him in the movie so if you're
wondering why he's sneaking around in a
hoodie in this shot it's because of the
way people view metahumans in the Batman
V Superman universe if you remember
during that bill people do not like
people with powers so even though the
flash has been saving people as we've
seen they're all trying to keep it under
the radar because it's still a pretty
new thing in the amazons have been gone
for so long that most people have
forgotten about them so really
Steppenwolf coming to earth looking for
the mother boxes for Darkseid is going
to be the crash course in metahumans
everywhere because people flipped when
they found out about Superman in the Man
of Steel movie oh my god there's this
alien on the planet how we going to deal
with this now you have to imagine that
times a thousand but let me know in the
comments what do you think about the
flying fox what do you think about all
these characters come together in how
long do you think it's going to be
before they put Superman in one of these
trailers but what's going to happen next
is is because Marvel saw the DC was
posting all this stuff they dropped the
new guardians of the galaxy trailer in a
whole bunch of new spider-man picks so
I'll do a Guardians video next that
we'll post in a couple hours so I'll say
congratulations to mr. Dan you're the
latest in Justice to giveaway winner
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there is a new round in
this video so I'll announce the winner
when I post that full of Justice League
trailer leave all your requests for
Justice League bonus videos in the
comments below what I'll probably do
tomorrow after I do the trailer video is
post something for the minions of
Darkseid we've been talking about the
heroes a lot but we haven't talked too
much about Darkseid's minions he has a
great team on his side like Kalibak
Steppenwolf will see Steppenwolf in the
movie so all that stuff coming tomorrow
maybe some new spider-man this weekend
too while you wait for that to post you
can click here for the other Justice
League videos that I posted and you can
click here for new guardians of the
galaxy footage thank you so much for
watching let's high five I'll see you
guys in the next video
you